what's going on guys this is Rob and
with future movies coming out from both
Fox and Disney based on the Marvel
Comics I thought it'd be pretty fun to
sort of go back and talk about different
Marvel characters some of whom are some
of my favorites some of whom have have
or have had a major impact on the Marvel
timeline or some who are just obscure
but deserve a little more attention and
I figured this first video could be
about a guy named mastermind or as most
people know him jason wyngarde
jason wyngarde was really kind of this
interesting character he wasn't a major
figure in the Marvel comics for a long
time he had this sort of pop up where he
appeared he had some important roles and
then he just kind of fell into obscurity
and then eventually died the first big
big event that he had was the fact that
he was an original founder of the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants now of
course magneto was the one that founded
the Brotherhood but he was one of the
first members alongside the Scarlet
Witch Quicksilver and toad now due to
the actions of an alien from another
dimension called the stranger who we
won't get into the original Brotherhood
was disbanded the next event that he got
himself into was his attempt to be
inducted into the inner circle of the
Hellfire Club which was a villainous
group reserved for premiere individuals
who were able to earn their way into
that group by demonstrating their
ability to basically go to any lengths
or to demonstrate just how powerful they
could be and they effectively had to
prove themselves as being worthwhile or
a member that was worth contributing to
the group now the way that he basically
auditioned was by using a mechanical
device known as a mind tap mechanism
that helped her augment his own mental
illusion powers to take over the mind of
Jean Grey as Phoenix force the powers of
jason wyngarde
allow him to manipulate the mind of a
human being or a group of human beings
so that they believe that what they hear
feel smell and taste are 100% true and
with the help of external mechanisms he
can affect the minds of people like
Charles Xavier or as we just said Jean
Grey is Phoenix force now when Jean Grey
became the Phoenix force she had put
these mental blocks in place to keep the
powers from basically running rampant
and causing all kinds of havoc as
mastermind had taken over her body or
taken over her mind and manipulated it
these mental blocks began to fall down
the last remaining mental block was her
tie to Cyclops and as Cyclops had
engaged in a mental battle with
mastermind in order to force him to
relinquish his control over Jean Grey he
ended up losing Cyclops lost and as a
result of this the final barrier in Jean
Grey's mind was removed and these forces
these Phoenix forces just flooded her
mind entirely the Phoenix force was this
elemental entity that had existed since
the formation of the universe and had
never really engaged in the emotional
feelings of the human race and so for
the Phoenix force to be engaged in the
emotional aspects love hate compassion
you know a desire to improve oneself
because the Phoenix force had never
experienced these it basically drove the
Phoenix force to a state of complete and
total insanity it was this rush to
experience as many emotions as possible
and to relish in the emotions that the
Phoenix force enjoyed the most when the
Phoenix force realized that it had been
manipulated by jason wyngarde it turned
jason wyngarde power against itself
against himself and threw him to a state
of insanity when the Phoenix force
exposed to him a glimpse of what godhood
was like now of course once jason
wyngarde was able to regain his sanity
he went through this state where he seek
revenge against everyone that he
believed had done him wrong
head-to-head screwed him over basically
he went on this tear to take revenge
against the x-men he went after
Wolverine where he basically kind of
duped his fiancee into breaking it off
with him and you know opening up ties
with the criminal underworld which kind
of left Wolverine in a state of complete
and total emotional destruction because
not only had he lost the woman that he
was truly in love with Jean Grey but he
had now found love and the woman that he
was with I think right in was mariko
yashida but I'm not going to I'm not
going to swear to that but he had found
love with her and had now been rebuked
the next was to take revenge
mystique or against rogue by forcing
rogue into a state of mental insanity by
breaking her ties or by unbalancing your
ties with Carol Danvers and sending
mystique into a state of turmoil and I
think he actually induced a nightmare
and let her know that he was letting
mystique know that he was the one that
was responsible he manipulated the x-men
into thinking that Cyclops is now fiance
who was the clone of Madeleine Pryor
into believing that she was a
reincarnation of the Dark Phoenix hoping
that the x-men would destroy Madeline
prior now the reason why Adeline Pryor
was a significant part of this plan was
because as Cyclops was in a state of
complete and total depression and when
he saw Madeline Pryor he immediately
latched on to her and believed that she
was Jean Grey reborn now because she was
a clone she thought that she was Jean
Grey for a long time she believed that
she was Jean Grey before she became the
cobbling of the Goblin Queen but
nonetheless after a time Cyclops
realizes what's going on and realizes
that this is basically mastermind behind
all this and the x-men defeat him in
short order it's really not much of a
battle at all he eventually tried to tap
into the Phoenix force but is defeated
by Rachel summers and Excalibur and is
in prison with a delusion that he has
achieved cosmic awareness eventually he
died a legacy virus and you know before
he before he kicked the bucket
he asked Jean Grey to forgive him you
know for everything that he had done and
of course she did and he was able to die
in peace
but he left a legacy in the sense that
he had three daughters two of which
became or have the same kind of powers
he did and one of which was had the
ability to fly
her name was pixie it also turns out
that he had orchestrated an illusion in
the mind of a extraordinarily powerful
mutant called the century and to believe
that if he had ever recalled his
abilities or used his powers also I
recalled who he was or used his powers
that the devil would attack man
which of course we'll get into that much
later on when we get to the century and
in Robert Reynolds and the void so with
that being said I hope you guys enjoyed
it again mastermind wasn't the most
prominent character in the history of
the Marvel Comics but he was cool and he
was interesting for what he was and he
was really kind of a fun character to
read about and to watch with his
engagements and here's a his ability and
his attempts to manipulate the Phoenix
force and to exploit it to his own ends
so with that said I'm gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys later peace